alors vous soyez alors vous mettez sur
le côté que vous voulez à droite ou à
gauche quand se remettre en selle
devient un rituel depuis 2018
l'association à vélo sans âge installée
sur Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines propose
aux personnes dépendantes des sorties
entre ville et nature grâce à deux
tricycles la trentaine de bénévoles
actifs se relaient pour donner à nos
aînés un goût de liberté objectif leur
permettre de garder le contact avec
l'extérieur et maintenir un lien social
l'intérêt du triporteur c'est que ça
casse la glace il y a pas besoin de
d'intermédiaires on est de plain-pied on
peut très facilement dire aux gens
bonjour et bien ils sont pas interloqués
ils répondent ils disent bonjour Avec
avec le sourire et on peut s'arrêter et
entamer une discussion attention je vais
klaxonner
je voulais pas vous écraser c'est pour
ça
au guidon de Félix Christian vient
plusieurs fois par mois pédaler pour les
personnes âgées de cet EHPAD situé à
Guyancourt sa motivation l'envie de
partager avec eux un moment privilégié
parfois la seule sortie de certains ça
me fait plaisir de d'offrir un peu de
bonheur au résidents je serai peut-être
content si dans plusieurs dizaines
d'années c'était moi qui était promené
par par des plus jeunes que moi donc
pendant que je peux le faire ben je le
fais
alors
on a besoin de sortir à l'extérieur pour
pour voir autre chose vous comprenez on
est quand même confiné pendant pendant
un an dans tout l'hiver dans
l'établissement des balades
personnalisées s'adaptent à la demande
de chaque bénéficiaire une bulle
d'évasion pour profiter de l'instant
présent cheveux au vent il y a des
grands-mères elles fondre devant les
enfants donc on va plutôt au devant des
enfants au devant des écoles au devant
des
des personnes avec des Landos bien il y
a des personnes qui sont plus sensibles
à nature donc on va plutôt soit voir les
moutons voir les voir les voir les jolis
coins
ensemble moi j'étais 41 ans à Paris et
ben
j'avais assez depuis le 1er janvier
dernier près de 550 adhérents ont pu
être transportés par l'association 50
chinoise pour les personnes à domicile
une cotisation annuelle de 15 euros et
demandée afin de pouvoir rouler à
volonté et retrouver une seconde
jeunesse